how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Happy Thanksgiving to everybody that is
celebrating that today I do want to say
thank you to everybody who has supported
me and my channel and I'll do that at
the end of the video today we have big
news to talk about it has been reported
that the villain of Black Panther 2 is
going to be the one and only Doctor Doom
that's right not Namor like everybody
thought it was going to be but Victor
Von Doom this is definitely not what we
expected however the report does make
perfect sense and this does line up with
some leaks that we've had in the past
and it's just a logical thing for Marvel
to do and the way that Doom is going to
enter the MCU in black panther according
to this report is very exciting and not
to mention if Doctor Doom is coming to
the MCU that means the Fantastic Four
are not far behind so we'll go into this
report but first if you're new be sure
to subscribe to my channel I do daily
Marvel videos also doing a giveaway
giving away an Xbox one or ps4 all you
have to do to enter is be subscribed to
my channel like this video and leave a
comment down below okay so like I said
it has been reported by charles murphy
that the main villain of black panther 2
is going to be dr. doom now this is
definitely a different way than i think
most people imagine that dr. doom would
be introduced into the MCU i think of
course most people thought that he was
going to be introduced in a Fantastic
Four movie however that has been done
before and Marvel obviously is going to
want to stay as far away from the Fox
Fantastic Four as possible so therefore
introducing Doctor Doom in black panther
2 makes perfect sense and the way that
he would enter black panther 2 makes
perfect sense as well this rumor claims
that Victor Von Doom is going to begin
expanding his empire into Africa and as
he expands his empire more and more into
Africa he will run into and come into
conflict with the nation of Wakanda and
T'Challa aka Black Panther who of course
will not like the fact that dr. doom is
trying to take over his territory now
this is pretty similar to the 2010 comic
event called doom war in Doom or dr.
doom actually invades Wakanda and search
for that precious and rare metal that
can only be found in Wakanda vibranium
and although the report doesn't
specifically mention that Doctor Doom
will be in search of vibranium it does
seem like they're going to be taking
some pages from that comic
and of course even if he isn't in
pursuit of vibranium once he discovers
what Conda and vibranium he's definitely
going to want to get his hands on it so
that is how this report claims that
Doctor Doom is going to enter blacc
panther2 now this does line up with
previous leaks that we've heard in the
past a few different people in the
community and Industry have stated that
the next big bad villain of the MCU is
going to be not only Doctor Doom but
Galactus as well splitting the MCU into
two different categories the earthbound
and the cosmic bound Galactus would
obviously be the main big bad villain of
the cosmos and of course Doctor Doom
would be the main big bad villain of
Earth so if these reports end up being
true which looks to be more and more
true as time goes on Doctor Doom may be
somewhat successful when he goes up
against black panther and in fact he may
even get his hands on some vibranium
making him more powerful because this
isn't going to be a one and done like
Ultron doctor dooms not just going to be
in one movie and then never appear in
the MCU again you know he has to show up
again at least for the Fantastic Four
but if they are setting him up to be a
major villain and the MCU we could
definitely expect to see him in many
different films it's definitely going to
be interesting to see black panther go
up against Doctor Doom in black panther
2 it should be a very interesting and a
very good fight but let me know what you
think about this news are you excited
that Doctor Doom is finally entering the
MCU and do you think that it's a good
idea to have him be introduced in Black
Panther 2 be sure to let me know in the
comments down below and again I just
want to say thank you to everybody who
has supported my channel over this year
and a half that I've started it it's
been way better than I ever thought it
could be and I owe it all to you so of
course like I always say thank you so
much for watching and thank you for
supporting my channel and that's why I
do the giveaways to give a little
something back right now of course Xbox
one and ps4 giveaway be sure to
subscribe like the video leave your
comments down below and of course I'll
see you all tomorrow thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
you